do you think anyone has ever had sex in
space
good question
um I think on the shuttle I might be
wrong here but I think there may have
been a married couple on the shuttle
that have been in space not to say that
they had sex whilst they're in space but
I think that there has been the
opportunity shall we say
um so do you think anyone's ever had sex
in space not sure
um do I think that people will have sex
in space absolutely space is opening up
at a commercial level we will
potentially have people you know
vacating on orbital hotels in space in
maybe 50 100 years time so if it hasn't
already happened it will do
that'll be the 400 kilometer mile high
club